okay so andrew garfield has been doing
the rounds with the press and talking
everything spider-man no way home this
includes what his and sony's reactions
to the leaks were and also what could be
happening with his version of peter
parker i want to get straight into it
but if you enjoy the video we'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up and
also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day now if
you cast your mind back to last year you
may remember that garfield appeared on
happy side confused which is where he
started playing the werewolf game with
the entire world i don't know how to
bring up the spider-man stuff because
obviously i don't even want to like ruin
anything if there is something to ruin
except there isn't anything to ruin bro
i have to just quickly just cut you off
there's nothing to ruin really
i promise you i am not the werewolf
garfield has finally come back to do a
follow-up interview in which he can
finally tell all so you're recording
immediately of course i want every
single juicy second with you buddy
hey you should start recording
immediately because
we
we you know we have some things to
discuss i'm so happy that we get to
follow up
on uh our last conversations
and tie up some loose ends and um
i can make amends to you andrew um do
you have any opening statement any any
preamble before we launch right in
oh my goodness like it's it's hard to
know
like it's hard it's hard to know if i
won the game of werewolf or if i lost it
or if i'm somewhere in between i am
the werewolf
and it was really fun to do that and to
play that with you
so there you have it he is the werewolf
we got him we got the sum of a [ __ ]
also on the last video i said he was a
cloud chaser because he was finally
admitting to being in the movie it was a
joke yeah i swear doubt it was a joke
please stop commenting please just just
leave me alone now garfield once more
becoming spider-man was one of the most
talked-about elements in the run-up to
norway home and in the theater it
definitely got one of the biggest
reactions with the audience that i
watched it with everyone was so happy to
see him back and because of this fans
are now looking to the future and when
his next appearance could be for me he
completely embodies peter parker and
spider-man and as someone who grew up on
the ultimate comics he feels like that
version brought to live action because
of this everyone is desperate to see him
back and though he remained tight-lipped
it was put to him if he would be up for
showing up in venom three
in terms of moving forward with the
character like yes i am definitely open
to that
and again it would have to be something
very unique very special and of service
to an audience of service to the
character
and um
i i i think there's
something playful and unique and odd
and
unexpected to be done i'm not sure what
that is but if we can figure it figure
that out that would be so much fun but i
mean a lot of folks have mentioned i
mean like you know you've got tom
hardy's venom out there you've got the
cool idea i mean and there's obviously
as you alluded to from the start you
always kind of wanted to mix it up with
the mcu now all bets are off i mean who
the hell knows you know i would love to
continue working with toby like and and
and with tom like i think that that kind
of three three brother dynamic is so
juicy now sony are a company that like
money and when you have an actor that's
so on board with the project i think
they'd be stupid to turn him down it has
been reported for a while now that
spider-man will be showing up in venom 3
and though people initially thought that
this meant tom holland i actually think
that it would be better to keep him in
the mcu and have the other spider-man
cross into venom's universe ever since
the spider-man right steel almost fell
through it's felt like sonia doing their
own things in terms of making sure that
they have a direction in case things
fall apart this is why projects like the
spider-verse movie is getting a sequel
and even properties like a madame web
film are being announced i think it
really is the best of both worlds to
have one version of the character off in
the mcu whilst the other established
ones appear in the sony films like venom
and mobius now the fact that he talks
about toby is another cool thing as i
think for the next outing people would
love to see those two team up once more
though they still had pretty big parts
in no way home i do kind of want to see
a story centered around them rather than
having them just drop into toms so yeah
set it up andrew garfield is so hot
right now and though he was initially
kind of brushed to the side by sony
after amazing spider-man 2. he's really
built a name for himself and can now
demand the big bucks from the company
you better lawyer up [ __ ] because i'm
not coming back for 30
i'm coming back for everything now when
discussing toby andrew has mentioned in
other interviews how there was a cut
scene in which he too had his own
injuries there was of course the back
one that made it to the movie but
garfield said the following in relation
to what was taken out of the film it was
so playful and creative and free and
like i love the fact that toby had his
back issues and i'm all like being his
friend by saying i have my back issues
too i was stretching at one point in
that scene like i was doing an old man
stretching before that moment which
didn't make the cut but i think it's
better that that was all toby's now
moving on from that he did talk about
what happened when he received the call
from amy pascal and kevin feige garfield
stated i felt very excited to just be a
fan again but i got this call from amy
pascal and kevin feige and john watts
with this idea it was immediately
undeniable on a base level as a
spider-man fan just the idea of seeing
three spider-men in the same frame was
enough the pitch was really really
enticing they said you played this
character in your own way and what would
you want to explore if you had an
opportunity if you were dumped into this
other universe and faced with this
younger you and this older you how will
you respond it was joyful and a feeling
of closure for me now in case you don't
know andrew was meant to be doing the
amazing spider-man 3 but he actually
ended up being reportedly dismissed by
the top brass at sony after he failed to
show up to an event in brazil where the
film was going to be announced andrew
was too sick to attend and during the
sony email hack it was brought to light
that amy pascal had been talking with
kevin feige this was about helping with
the reboot of the web head which would
tie into the mcu it seemed like andrew
wouldn't come back but now i hope he's
getting everything now no way home was
one of the most spoiled movies of all
time and andrew got asked every time
there was a camera around whether he was
in the film or not the guy actually
started to look exhausted by the end of
it but he has confirmed he kept this lie
up and didn't even tell emma stone are
mark and emma like were they plugged in
like did you ever talk to them have they
still know if they've seen the movie
like is that like what's their awareness
of this
emma kept on texting me and she was like
are you in this new spider-man film
and i was like
i don't know what you're talking about
what you're still walking out with him
she was like shut up just tell me i'm
like i honestly don't know what i kept
it going even with her as hilarious
to the end you never admitted to emma no
and then she and then she saw it she's
like you're a jerk
that's a true actor right there and he
deserves an oscar for his performance in
2021 now you might remember that there
was also a doordash delivery guy who
said that he saw garfield andrew cleared
this up and confirmed that it was true
and he said that it was the first night
he arrived in atlanta and he was hanging
out with one of his best friends from
the walking dead he said he masked up
and thought that that would be enough
but the guy asked for id which made him
panic andrew said he then started asking
why he needed a show id because he was
so worried about getting caught luckily
his friend intervened but as the
doordash guy said can't forget the guy
who dropped gwen never forgive never
forget anyway keeping that's a joke by
the way before you start typing because
i know what some of you kids are like
anyway keeping everything a secret was
difficult and there was of course the 8k
video of andrew garfield in the suit
that released last year garfield said
that he asked amy pascal about what to
do because clearly the cat was out the
bag however the werewolf wasn't and she
just told him to keep shtum clearly it
worked though as no way home is the
highest grossing movie this side of the
pandemic anyway that wraps up a lot of
the new talking points in the film and i
just want to shout happyside confused as
i know i use a lot of their clips in
this video i tend to avoid putting
direct audio and video into a lot of my
breakdowns but it just sounds better
coming directly out of their mouths
instead of my stupid one definitely go
check out the full episode of the show
though as they talk about a lot more and
in the meantime i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the interviews we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of an mc boxer of your
choice on the 30th of january and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our first video in
which andrew finally talks all he goes
over a lot of things that we didn't
cover in this one and it's a really good
listen so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
paul you've been the best i'll see you
on the next one take care peace